- [Voiceover] Triangle ABC
undergoes a translation,
and we're using the
notation capital T for it,
and then we see what the
translation has to be.
We're gonna move,
it's kind of small, I hope you can see it
on your video screen.
We're gonna move positive eight.
Every point here is
gonna move positive eight
in the x direction.
Its x coordinate is going
to increase by eight,
or the corresponding point in the image,
its x coordinate, is going
to increase by eight,
and the corresponding point
in the image's y coordinate
is going to decrease by
one, so let's do that.
And I'll focus on the vertices,
whoops, let me drag that to the trash,
I didn't mean to do that.
I'm going to focus on the vertices
well, that's just the
easiest thing for my brain
to worth with.
And actually, this is what
the tool expects as well.
So the point B, is going to move eight
to the right, or its corresponding point
in the image is going
to have an x coordinate
eight larger.
So right now, the x
coordinate is negative four,
if you added eight to that,
it would be positive four,
and its y coordinate is going
to be one lower.
Right now, point B's
y coordinate is eight,
one lower than that is seven.
So, in the image, the corresponding
point of the image would
going to be right over there.
And you see we moved eight to the right,
and one down.
Let's do that with point C.
It's at x equals negative seven,
if you move eight to the right,
if you increase your
x coordinate by eight,
you're gonna move to x equals one,
and then if you change your y coordinate
by negative one, you're
gonna move down one,
then you're gonna get to that point
right over there.
Now, let's do it with point A.
So point A's x coordinate is negative one.
If you add eight to it,
it's going to be positive seven,
and its current y coordinate is two.
If you take one away from it,
you're gonna get to a y coordinate of one.
And so there you have it.
Let's see, how do I connect these two?
Oh, there you go,
and we can check our answer.
And we got it right.
We have performed the translation.